c'est par la connaissance de l'histoire
aux prises et j'ai rien et qu est l
étape avant une faune et aux chercheurs
qu'ils avaient été noués voulez vous
quand nous promenons nous allons
justement revivre eux recherchent
oui qu'est-ce que le catharisme
il faut remonter au moyen âge c'était
vos colonnes les initiés avait une
faculté de religion qui s'est perdu
ensuite au cours des âges et pourquoi
invité de vision c'est à dire que il
voyait les entités spirituelles hésiter
un rapport direct comme ça par région et
par la parole par l'audition entités
spirituelles savez qu'il ya de meilleur
chez les âges cajarc aille jusque
jusqu'au ses refrains et cette faculté
là j'ai perdu parce qu'il fallait que
nous arrivions à développer leur
intelligence clair ensuite beaucoup de
temps à jouer sur george steiner qui a
expliqué une manière très précise est
alors que ses formes et la théologie
aristotélicienne dans le catholicisme
parce que tout d'abord la philosophie
qatar correspondait à la doctrine de
platon savez le prétend expliquer que ce
que nous voyons dans le monde visible
tic le reflet d'un vigile la réalité
vraie étaient occultes visible puis
ensuite aristote a voulu voir les
réalités le même oui et un théologien
catholique a montré que j'étais enfin se
lancer dès qu'il fallait voir dans les
choses
l'expression des réalités spirituelles
c'est thomas d'aquin qui
mais si tu le joues fille qui en restait
donc matic l'église catholique et on a
été en effet il fallait que nous
arrivions à développer le riz ne pensait
clair ne triche pas on ne peut en
entendre dire que c'est une pensée
mentent mais nous sommes à une époque où
grâce
allez ici comme une rue voltaire
nous devons de nouveau vivifier cette
pensée froide créé la robe louis ces
remous vivante et qui n ont pas dense et
active
nous sommes partir la pensée fron parce
qu'allah nous étions nous conservions
notre libre telle pensée pour lucie
vivait pas dans nos méditation nous
voyons un objet
rien aux hommes nous avons une image
ken mais nous ne voyons pas les fausses
vivante qui agissent qui se manifestent
nous nous voyons que l'ecosse les choses
et soie rose on arrive par un certain
entraînement moderne un rat voile quand
un lac en plein air au 1er mai ou un
objet ce soit de la répulsion ou de
l'attraction
quand on est attiré par la vie le nombre
important soit pas pas seulement un
souvenir qui sait comme morneau mais les
fausses vivante qui constituent cet
arbre on le revoit son écosse les forces
vives
c'est pas si vous suiviez bien qu est-ce
qui a suivi le mouvement qatar qui était
interdit en tant que reese seront
bordelais houle a persisté jusqu'au
15ème siècle eh bien il ya eu une
transformation de censure motion qui
était tout d'abord une connu par une
légende qui descend vers israël ensuite
quand on connaît les faits qui ont suivi
la destruction la répression du
catharisme ce que les gens disaient que
des 14 mimi de la france était allée en
souabe avait un château de guerre mais
là où j'ai rencontré un jeune homme qui
savait initiés et ce jeune homme la
capern dans la grèce est allé ensuite en
asie mineure
il a fait son chemin de damas il a
rencontré la d'egis malien lui musulman
il se trouve que les i maliens étaient
les successeurs de faire de la pub des
musulmans qui à leur époque avait
organisé un cours en r est une toxine
qui concourait et celle des cathares you
fera péter qatar jean-louis nos fins
et puis il malien qui
faisait réussite défaire de la pureté et
c'est là que jean cras à retrouver
l'initiation kata qui était repris sous
une nouvelle forme
au lieu d'organiser les églises à
l'image des gis malien musulmans des
fichiers il le parti de la connaissance
du monde physique du monde brigitte à
l'animal humain est recherché comment se
former ces organismes et étudier les
fluence les planètes cours de notre
révolution est celle que des forces
jodias qualité de finition messieurs
nous est là en partance de ses
connaissances il est remonté
aucun sens et spirituelle il n'y pas de
nouvelles ce qui précisément a été
reprise au cours des siècles et qui vous
semblent vivre librement splendide
c'est ce que nous appelons les
collections suspect rituel de dornach
organisées par river of time qui la cei
l'ins avait rencontré reste coi
quantique
j'aime bien longtemps sans dieu je tiens
n'a plus équipe archets de l'acquis qui
l'a porté au cours sylviane sérielle a
pu ensuite faire de nouvelles
découvertes
ce en sus la connaissance publique
alumine courant néo zélandais bill gates
c'était celui des nouveaux 1000 qui
portait des commandes à rians au dieu
unique et ce qu'ils attaquent érigé la
théologie c'est que il les années
théologie de l ue ce qui était considéré
comme hérétique
j'ai de la possession de l'esprit avant
midi christ en rampant père inconnu et
les galères de je vois le problème du
mal mais ensuite il ya eu l'école
monique n vous convainquez venue de la
jmj miller de la chine albanie qui était
au sud du caucase
sachant que dans le midi on appelait
les premiers à des arrières du qatar dit
le libre-échange l'occident parce que
j'étais caractérisée par le fait que je
m'étais la théologie de ricin et ensuite
j'ai produit le mouvement qui venait
dans l'ancienne albanie qui était
mannequin où il était distingue
nettement de force ça du bien celle du
mal de l'esprit de la matière
annuellement dans ce courant importé
d'idéalisme
mais tous le même alain admettant qu'il
y aurait un dieu absolu qu'on ne saisit
pas directement l aria une troisième
école celle de l'église de conques au
réseau qui précisément a fait la
synthèse des deux couronnes mondiales
risque ou grezzo parce que ce mouvement
jose au ficg ou théologiques et sortie
d'une église qui était concours raison
en italie alors là selon hé hé oui nous
admettons un dieu unique mais dans le
monde virtuel est en nous il se
manifeste par des principes nous apprend
le principe du biel principe du mans
son projet en réalité dans le monde
actuel you may ce que vous n'avez pas
pensé réunir tout ce que vous avez dit
tout ce que vous avez écrit
mais oui personnellement j'ai en
préparation dumont ensemble déterminé
que j'ai je suis reparaître élections
ont fait toujours l'interdiction après
comme ça on annonce que ceux qui vont
sortir sains et sûrs
oh
parmi les choses qui me qui me peine se
trouve là la disparition d'un d'un vieil
esprit de fête
il n'existe plus maintenant qu'il
n'existe plus comme avant
voyez autrefois dans les villages de
notre langue d'oc et avait pour les
fêtes de noël toujours une petite
représentation qui était donné par les
gens du cru les gens du coin et c'était
véritablement un événement ont préparé
ça les costumes ont préparé la salle 7
les merveilleuses il y avait plus de
parti politique à ce moment tout le
monde tout le monde travaille et l'allée
l'instituteur ratée donnait là bas au
curé et puis tout le monde mettait en
scène
c'est cette fête annuelle
je me rappelle d'une en particulier
qu'elle j'avais et nash collaborer jeudi
et la sppf je prêtais un succès terrible
nous représentions m'a trompé moi
l'annoncé faite à marie lui pas eu du
tout sur un texte de claude et ali il
s'en faut
c'était c'était tout simplement lange
qui devaient annoncer à la sainte vierge
qu'elle allait avoir un bébé alors
l'enjeu on l'avait monté dans les dents
les lustres et il devait descendre bout
d'une corde avec une poulie mais le
système de la machinerie était pas
excellent alors on rit d'abord
apparaître sous le
le petit de l'homme nous père de grands
pieds et des jambes venue lorsque la
robe de lange avait remonté et en même
temps comme la poulie était trop bien
centrer il tournait il tournait il
tournait était furieux parce que les
sols la salle rigolait bien entendu est
tactile et quand il a eu suffisamment
insulté le machiniste il a quand même
pris peur on a rajouté sa robe des
français c'est elle il s'est avancé vers
la bonne mère qui était à l'autre bout
de la salle de l'art de la scène à 6 ans
une bergère louis 15 et qui tricoter et
il a dit bonjour marie je suis un âge et
à 5 à 10 h 10
remettez-vous il me rappelle de ça avec
tendresse
parce qu'on peut plus voir des choses
pareilles la télévision ont supprimé la
possibilité m'amena ce genre de
spectacle on a tous les acteurs du monde
chez soi tous les soirs mais je regarde
si bien la fête d'autrefois